تحتفل المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
بذكرى تاسيسها الاولى قبل ثلاثه قرون هذه
الذكرى التي امتدت لاجيال عده وحملت معها
الكثير من البناء والعمل يوم بدينا هو
شعار هذا العام ومعه تستمر المملكه في
مسيرتها الناصعه بالصناعه الحاضر المميز
الذي يستند الى الارث العريق ثلاثه قرون
من البناء الدؤوب والسعي بامل الى التطور
الذي زاد في السنوات الاخيره مع رؤيه عام
2030 التي تطمح المملكه الى تحقيقها اليوم
يحتفل السعوديون بذكرى تاسيس دولتهم ومن
المنطقه الشرقيه سنكون مع عبد الرحمن
القصيمي للحديث عن ابرز مظاهر وفعاليات
هذا اليوم السعودي الكبير
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم لنا مراسله صباح العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن هلا يسعدلي
هالطله اهلا بك اين انت عبد الرحمن ومن
اعرق الاسواق السعوديه نتعرف على فعاليات
اليوم السعودي الكبير معك تفضل
نعم سهام نحن من سوق القيصريه في الحسا
هذا السوق الذي تاسس عام
1862 والدوله السعوديه الاولى انتهت عام
1891 اي ان هذا السوق
تاسس قبل انتهاء الدوله السعوديه الثانيه
29 سنه فهو عاصرت الدوله السعوديه الثانيه
والدوله السعوديه الثالثه ونجحاتها
والازدهار والتنميه طبعا اليوم لابس لكم
الزي السعودي القديم زي ما انتم شايفين
معايا البشت ومعي ايضا في المنتصف المجند
هذا الزي الذي كان من خلاله المقاتلين في
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه والثالثه يلبسونه
وايضا يتزينون فيه بالمناسبات الوطنيه
وايضا لابس اليوم العقال المقصه بهذا
العقال الذي ايضا كان يلبسه اجدادنا خلال
السنوات
الماضيه حتى عهد الملك عبد العزيز الملك
المؤسس للدوله السعوديه الثالثه كان يرتدي
هذا العقال وايضا ملك والملك فيصل لكن بعد
تقريبا السبعينات ميلاديه هذا العقال بدا
يندثر وتم استبداله بالعقال الاسود الذي
موجود حاليا طبعا احنا سوق قيصريه ونبغى
نتجول ونشوف الشباب ما شاء الله الجميلين
اللي متجهزين اليوم الاسم الكريم عبد
الهادي عبد الرحمن عبد الهادي انت ما شاء
الله اليوم لابس وكاشخ وعقال مقصب وتشد
وين رايح وين حتحتفل والله في مهرجان
كثيره مثل القيصريه والتمور في اماكن عده
كبيره
متحمس واليوم فرحه للشعب السعودي
انتباهي واحد من الشباب تقرب بس شوي اسمه
كريم
انت ما شاء الله بعد اليوم متحمس جاي بدري
الصباح
مع الاهل ايش الاجواء من القلب
اصاله العصر القديم
القيصريه نستمتع بالاجواء الاشياء القديمه
الجميله نست يعطيك العافيه يلا انبسطوا
اليوم طبعا احنا في السوق القيصريه هذا
السوق مشهور ببيع الملابس القديمه والسوق
طبعا مستعد وعلى هبه استعداد نادين وسهام
منذ تقريبا اسبوعين البضائع الملابس
القديمه العقال المقصب
الملابس الاطفال النساء كلها جاهزه هنا
والناس ما شاء الله في اقبال كبير طبعا
اليوم اجازه من الحكومه في المدارس
والجهات الحكوميه وايضا القطاع الخاص
والشركات كلهم اليوم اجازه لكن رغم
الاجازه شوف ما شاء الله الناس موجوده في
السوق بدري عشان تجهزون طبعا نشوف هنا
الملابس النسائيه يعني زي هالفستان هذا
سهام ونادين هذا الفستان مثلا يعني يمثل
زي السعوديات لا هذا نسائي ما ينفع البسه
لكن ممكن ممكن
بنات قائمه هدايا من عيوني من عيوني
لعيوني الان طبعا انا كتير عجبتني دمج انا
كتير عجبني روح الماضي مع روح الحاضر هذا
الدمج اللي انت عملنا اياه اليوم من خلال
هذا المباشر سواء بالزي واحتفاء بيوم
التاسيس لو انا اليوم عبد الرحمن موجوده
في المنطقه الشرقيه وين لازم اروح شو هي
الفعاليات اللي لازم اعملها
وين ما تروحي يا نديم وين ما تروحي كل
مكان وكل بقعه في السعوديه اليوم تحتفل
بيوم التاسيس هنا في المنطقه الشرقيه عندك
في الدمام
فعاليات في السوق الحب عندك في مركز اثراء
او اليوم ان شاء الله يكون مباشر على
الهواء من مركز اثراء تقريبا الساعه
الرابعه مساء عندك القيصريه في الحسا في
القطيف في مركز الرامز في العواميه
الكورنيش الخبر في العاب ناريه في الفرق
الشعبيه في يعني فعاليات كثيره لكن قبل ما
اختم بس برضو عشان انتباهي واحد من الشباب
هنا لابس برضه صباح الخير
اخوكم ز جوهر طبعا انت من جيل يعني قبل
الجيل الحديث شوي يعني ما شاء الله شكل
عمرك يعني انت عصرت يمكن عصر اجدادك وعصرت
الان العصر الحديث السعوديين
قيامهم مختلفت ولا تزال كما زالت والحمد
لله متمثل
ما عهدنا به السابق من اجدادنا واهلنا
والحمد لله لا زلنا مواصلين عليها يعطيك
العافيه اليوم الرائحه والله اليوم جايين
ناخذ للوالد
مشالح اللي هو البشته الحساوي وكذلك ان
شاء الله ناويين نزور بعض المواقع اللي هو
الاثريه من زميلتي تسالني تقول اللي
بالشرقيه وين يروح اليوم فقلها وين نروح
اليوم اليوم ما شاء الله اكثر شيء يكونون
زياره للقصريه كمان انتم موجودين كذلك
للمدرسه الاميريه خلفها والكوت ما شاء
الله في متسع كبير من المحلات والاثريه
نعرفكم عليه بعد قليل طبعا نادين وشهد
شاهدوا من اهلها يعني اهل الحساء علموك
وين تروحين اليوم
تمام واكيد يعني ما بننسى التمر الحساوي
يعني اللي جربناه في السعوديه كمان واحنا
بنشكرك عبد الرحمن احنا مستمرين بهذه
التغطيه في اليوم التاسيس وكمان راح
نستضيف المعلم السعودي والفيديو الشهير
اللي في السوشيال ميديا التلاميذ اللي عم
بيغنوا وطن الحبيب للراحل طلال مداح بعد
شوي خليك معانا كمان الى اللقاء عبد
الرحمن العصيمي